ONIECW YORK TIMES"
TAYLOR SFT CLOSEENCES IN TAYLOR
T'NA
PAST SOMWIST HASAIIN THE
"THE NEW H
CNN'S OLIVER DARCY JOI US LIVEWH
I MEAN, HOL IS IT FOK TIMES" TH
INNALYZING WHY "THE NEW YORK
.S
I , YO NOT SEE MAJE "THE NEW
YORK T"
NE SSOMEONE LIKELOR SW A
TU
FO
.UBLISHN S WHAT THEY
OPINION SECTN QUESTIONINHER
SEXUOUGHSWIFT IN THE PMEIG
OF THE LGBTQ, THATT O SHOWAS TH
.
AND S WHAT'SOF CRITICISMF "THE,T
"THE NEW YORK S.Y ARE NOO LE
MEECOF THETE
MEN
THERE IS A IN PELE ETHS.THIS ARO
SEXUALITIONED BY
THE NO
UNTRUE, INAPPRHOW
UNDE N INION PIECE.
"THE NEW YORK TI
COEN,
REDI O THEY HAVENTED WO WROTE  M
MARK, I KNHA
DIF A
STUEA FORMAL
ARATIODES IP-FUELED TO
SSION.
I SHARED MANY OFHO
RESERVATIONS, BUT THE STORIEOMR
IMAGHA OUR CULTURE
S ARTISTS TON ARTIST SIGNALS
AND  FALLS OAF DICE.IZING THE P
TO TAYLOR SWIFT DOT FEEL
BAD BLOON THEM AND N FOR  THIS
PA
ES,"
, WHILNA
SPONDE "THE NEW
YORK TIMES" ALMOSTAS
T
BECAUSE THE TERIA
MEED AS TOHAE T.
S "THE NEW YORK TIMES,"
THER BE AN EXPLANATION
OFHAE OBJECTIVE HEREAND THR ASOI
SOINTHIS MEAAT IS E OBJECTIVE HI
>> AND THE TIMES
TAYING SILENT.U' EDITORIAL
LEADER LIKE THHEE
NEEDED TO PUBLISH THIS STORYTHES
ENOUGH TAK
S SOMEONE'IT IT
IN "THE NEW YORK TIMES."
PAORD,O USUALLY ME I
THEIR STANDARDS ARE T HIGHERORG.
TIDHINGS ORGANIZATIONS WOULD
NOT DOBUEY'RE NO.
HAOTE, WHAT I JUSTREAD TO YOU,
FOR PUBLISHIN
DO FEEL THE MOREE FIELDING CRITT
ME HERE,
AND THATT SE T METITH A WHHOOF
>>ONLYTHAT'S REAIT ANDAWAY
ISM FOR THIS PIECE BECAUSE
OF THAT.
IT WILL BE INTERESTING TEY DO RM
OF THIVET YO
OPE ORBINE
LIKE TAYLOR SWIFG